la epilepsia es una afección en el
cerebro que se produce cuando una
persona sufre al menos dos crisis a lo
largo del tiempo
las unidades operativas básicas del
cerebro son las células nerviosas
llamadas neuronas envían mensajes
químicos y eléctricos entre sí así como
las glándulas y los músculos todo lo que
pensamos sentimos y hacemos es el
resultado de esta actividad
normalmente estos mensajes se envían de
manera ordenada si su hijo tiene
epilepsia varios grupos de neuronas
envían muchos mensajes a la vez
este aumento anormal de la actividad
eléctrica se llama crisis convulsiva hay
muchos tipos de crisis pero se pueden
agrupar en dos categorías principales
la primera categoría llamada crisis
generalizada afecta a todo el cerebro a
la vez
la segunda categoría de crisis se llama
crisis parcial o focal afectan sólo a
una parte del cerebro
los síntomas pueden variar dependiendo
del tipo de crisis los síntomas pueden
incluir pérdida del conocimiento
espasmos musculares
sensaciones extrañas ver u oler cosas
que no están ahí
confusión mirar al vacío o parpadeo
rápido
la mayoría de las crisis duran desde
unos pocos segundos hasta unos minutos
sin causar daño si una crisis dura más
de cinco minutos o si una persona se
lastima o está en peligro durante la
crisis llame al 911 en la mayoría de los
casos la causa de la epilepsia es
desconocida pero puede ser causada por
otras afecciones en el cerebro como
lesiones
infecciones defectos congénitos
accidentes cerebrovasculares o tumores
si tiene alguna duda sobre la epilepsia
hablé con su proveedor de atención
médica